عقد وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه ونظيره
الياباني يوشي ماساهيوشي وزيرات دفاع لويس
اوستن وياسو كازا هامادا مؤتمر صحفيا في
العاصمه الامريكيه واشنطن جدد اوستن خلاله
التزام الولايات المتحده بالدفاع عن
اليابان بكل ما اوتيت من قوه بما فيها
النوويه كما قال هو السن ان بلاده ستنشر
في جزيره اوكيناوا في جنوب اليابان وحده
لتدخل السريع من سلاح المارينز للتعزيز
القدرات الدفاعيه لحليفتها في مواجهه
التهديدات الصينيه المتزايده وكشف وسطنا
انه سيوقعوا مع نظيره الياباني العديده من
الاتفاقيات الدفاعيه مشيرا الى رصد زياده
في النشاطات الصينيه في المضائق
شاهيناز
ان اجدد التزام الولايات المتحده بالدفاع
عن اليابان بكل ما اوتيت من قوه بما فيها
النوويه وقد باركنا في لقائنا اليوم قرار
طوكي اكتساب القدرات لتوجيه ضربات المضاده
وساوقع مع نظير الياباني على ترتيبات
جديده تتيح للمؤسسات الدفاعيه في البلدين
التعاون الوثيقه في مجال التقنيات
المتطوره